good day be home by dinner I love you
good morning Catherine
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
Catherine hey hey you found her
we and Catherine are doing on day in
those woods we were just walking I'm
walking
Angela can you tell your dad how long
you were gone a few hours
baby you've been gone three days
laughs
[Music]
what'd you say I didn't say nothing
I thought I heard you say something
hey baby
okay
wherever those girls who went there
brought something back with them the
body and the blood of Jesus Christ
put it in the blood the body in the
blood
Catherine body in the blood
the body and the blood the body and the
blood count for the body
ever seen anything like this
on me no but there are people out there
who have
[Music]
[Applause]
you have some experience with possession
yes more than that like
I believe you can help get our girls
back
exorcism is a ritual every culture every
religion they all use different methods
it's going to take all of them
[Music]
we've met before
mother
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do
is that Catherine's heartbeat they're
beating in shape
God played a trick on me
[Music]